en 2019 le Sénat décide de mettre en
place une loi anti-fessée pour bannir
les violences éducatives sur les enfants
la loi interdisant la fessée à
définitivement été adoptée alors pour
éduquer leurs enfants certains parents
n'hésitent pas à les punir en les
envoyant dans leur chambre mais
aujourd'hui cette pratique est remise en
cause par certains spécialistes c'est
une sanction psychique inouïe et je pèse
mes mots si on veut que l'enfant se
calme il faut rester avec lui tandis que
85% des parents estiment qu'il est
difficile d'élever un enfant sans crier
le Conseil d'Europe des conseils donc
aux parents de dire aux enfants de filer
dans leur chambre pour les punir non on
n'est pas d'accord
elle dit des bêtises merci de me citer
mais Miguel ton partenaire de paddle
avait l'info Miguel c'est un espagnol
avec qui joue qui est un partenaire avec
qui je suis quelqu'un voilà donc merci
on verra
bien savoir qui sont ces gens pour payer
avec de l'argent public qui nous
explique comment vivre enfin là on nous
explique quand même que dire c'est ta
chambre à un enfant c'est un traumatisme
psychologique ça va être quoi vous voyez
les enfants parce que les tutoyés c'est
une agression enfin c'est insupportable
qu'ils arrêtent de de réfléchir à des
sujets dont tout le monde se fout et qui
se concentre sur des vrais problèmes
concrets c'est qui ces gens qui décident
ça c'est n'importe quoi il y a quand
même un gars dans l'émission [ __ ] fait
ouais ouais Bernard d'accord avec tout
le monde non c'est pourquoi mais parce
qu'il a raison aussi c'est le Conseil de
l'Europe c'est l'éducation dites
positive et comme la fessée tout ça
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi vu que chacun fait comme il veut ah
bah non elle a fait c'est non pardon
alors le sol peut pas mettre la seule
qui est d'accord on va pas laisser
parler Luluberlu ah il y a Géraldine
aussi les deux univers lutte Gilles
Verdez enfermé dans une chambre c'est
briser un enfant donc arrêtons avec en
train de nous les briser
unir c'est abêtir arrêtez avec ça la
chambre seule l'enfant est traumatisé à
vie enfermé et pourquoi pas dans le noir
et avant il y avait la fessée
il faut arrêter avec ça Cyril plus de
punition ça ne sert à rien alors il y a
le stagiaire qui qui est encore qui a 12
ans n'importe quoi mon vieux moi j'ai
elle me mettait dans ma chambre et
pourtant aujourd'hui
[Rires]
bien sûr voilà
bien sûr voilà et ta mère elle te dit de
te mettait dans ta chambre ouais bah oui
moi aussi
sa mère après plus parce qu'elle a été
tellement grand j'étais tellement grand
plaisir oui alors c'est un peu de nuance
à l'emportement de Gilles effectivement
quand on dit un gamin fil dans ta
chambre la chambre c'est son royaume
c'est le royaume de de son sommeil c'est
le royaume là où il va jouer c'est donc
un moment d'évasion pour lui donc ça
veut dire qu'on associe il va associer
tous les pédopsychiatre disent la
chambre comme un lieu de punition et de
châtiment et c'est ça le problème et je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un bon
c'est un bon conseil dire à son enfant
quand il est en pleine crise etc va dans
ta chambre réfléchir moi et du coup on
associe la chambre à un lieu de
réflexion un lieu d'apaisement un lieu
où il y a pas de stress donc voilà on
peut tordre les trucs dans tous les sens
et j'étais même j'étais dans des
colonies et moi j'avais un animateur je
veux dire que c'est vrai et quand on
faisait des conneries tout ça il va te
laver les fesses
nous envoyer dans notre chambre
toute la journée
mais qu'est-ce qu'on entend comme
connerie ce matin j'écoutais Europe 1 le
groupe c'est écouter Europe 1
après
il y avait une meuf je sais pas du tout
bah oui et qui expliquait que déjà par
exemple dire à un enfant c'était texto
dire à un enfant va embrasser ta
grand-mère c'est le dépôt CD de son
corps et de sa volonté
je suis désolé arrêtez de penser tous
ces trucs de pédopsychiatre c'est des
conneries par exemple la fessée tu
paries de la fessée moi je suis désolé
quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai j'ai pas
été à l'école une journée bon mon père
là-dessus il m'a attendu il m'a mis une
claque mais après toute ma vie j'ai
associé c'est chez l'école à une claque
et ben j'ai plus sécher l'école voilà un
enfant ça marche à la récompense
physique un enfant qui a fait une bêtise
c'est pas du sentiment physique un
enfant mais évidemment que je suis pour
la gifle mais ça veut pas dire battre un
enfant merci moi j'ai déjà reçu deux
claques que j'étais petit mon père moi
j'aimais battu enfin comment expliquer
c'est ça pour moi c'est un sentiment
c'est hallucinant arrêtez de penser que
c'est les enfants peuvent tout décider
que un enfant qui puisse contre un mur
c'est de la création il faut surtout pas
l'arrêter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les murs dont son appartement il a
dit surtout surtout ne l'arrêtent pas il
est en train de dire quelque chose il
crée ben non il est en train de [ __ ]
un mur
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes pas bien hein
j'ai été élevé
et alors ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui je
pense que ça évolué aussi la
pédopsychiatrie a évolué je pense qu'il
y a des choses qui peuvent traumatiser
les enfants des gifs ça peut traumatiser
des enfants des claques dans la tronche
ça peut traumatiser des enfants donc il
faut pas à l'école je t'en mets deux
fois je te disais Mathieu je te disais
Mathieu c'est pas il dit il en a eu pris
une dans toute sa vie une fois j'ai
associé effectivement c'est chez les
cours à la claque qui m'a eu pour mettre
des claques aux enfants pour rien
évidemment
qui est que si tu mets une claque une
fois à ton fils tu Bates ton fils
arrêtez ces associations horribles qui
c'est toi ça tu vois moi
j'avais oublié je crois que c'est pas
d'accord avec lui bah pas du tout non
mais je vous rappelle aujourd'hui quand
même taper son enfant c'est direct au
tribunal mais heureusement pardon taper
arrête avec une jupe de fess ça peut
vous conduire très Benjamin t'es pas
d'accord
j'ai été trop gentil avec eux il y a un
manque d'autorité on en parle tous les
jours ici il y a toujours des
débordements il faut arrêter de mettre
l'enfant en roi et le protéger c'est pas
arrêté les les enfants ça doit c'est ça
doit s'élever s'éduquer merci voilà
c'est le B a bas et je regrette vraiment
j'aurais dû être plus dur avec eux
pour mais honnêtement un enfant ça doit
s'élever c'est du quai et aujourd'hui on
peut plus rien faire c'est débile de ne
pas dire à ce moment de son enfant va
pas dans ta chambre ça veut dire quoi
honnêtement il y a depuis des décennies
on a fait ça et maintenant bien sûr on
peut pas dans ta chambre
et ça c'est des gars c'est des gars
comme toi c'est ce qu'ils ont dit ça les
mecs qui servent à rien
mais c'est des mecs comme toi
la France qui perd salut va travailler
va travailler là je vais faire service
parentalité du Conseil d'Europe non mais
sérieux mais vas-y parce que c'est des
mecs qui servent à rien et qui qui sont
comme toi qui croient tout savoir tu es
écoute moi bien le symbole de
la société est celle de l'échec je te le
redis et tu es pas loin d'être avec lui
sont très bien élevés très bien dans
leur j'ai vu la dernière fois
[Rires]
le principe des enfants déjà ceux qui
veulent prendre le pouvoir et c'est
normal il teste et c'est normal c'est
pour ça que j'aime pas non plus les
papas qui sont pas pas copains dont on
perd c'est ton père c'est pas ton copain
et qu'est-ce que tu fais quand on gamin
veut te tester un petit peu notamment
ton père voilà ton fils et ton père et
qui il est insolent qui te parle très
très mal tu vois il y a plein de gens
qui disent il y a tapé et réprimé merci
avec une gifle on va où là mais rien à
voir ça on n'a pas dit qu'il voulait
taper les enfants c'est personne va dire
ça personne va dire
c'est démodé je suis désolé aujourd'hui
on discute avec
il y a quelqu'un qui lui a un truc très
intéressant si on veut vraiment punir un
enfant on le met devant la télé pour
regarder écouter les conneries de Gilles
Verdez
Sébastien
qui dit Cyril n'était pas un enfant roi
et regardez ce qui est devenu cet abruti
[Rires]
on parle toujours de l'autorité à
l'école il faut commencer à la maison
excuse-moi parce qu'après il y a des
vrais problèmes on en parle toutes les
semaines ici les enfants violents etc il
faut les éduquer il y a beaucoup de gens
qui rallient sur mon pote Guillaume
voilà qui me dit aussi bah moi mdr la
fessée moi j'avais le martinet là
au-dessus de l'armoire et je peux te
dire que je faisais pas le malin
[Musique]
ce que tu veux dire Mathieu je viens à
la rescence de Mathieu est-ce que vous
êtes en train de tous lui faire dire ce
qui dit pas merci il faut taper les
enfants il dit juste il est pour les
réprimander voilà mais pas il n'a pas
pour mettre des gîtes aux enfants c'est
n'importe quoi il faut craindre son père
un tout petit peu et en avoir peur et
c'est normal ce n'est pas ton copain
c'est pas ton pote c'est une autorité
parentale mais les enfants ne me
craignent pas du tout voilà c'est moi
qui craint mes enfants
non mais sérieux moi je sors moi je sais
que mes enfants me mettent des coups de
pression mon fils m'appelle tu es où tu
rentres tout de suite non mais je finis
un truc tu rentres tout de suite je te
dis que c'est vrai mais c'est vrai la
dernière fois je t'ai rendu chez vous
allez faire une soirée je lui ai dit je
rentre à minuit et demi à minuit et demi
il m'a appelé il m'a dit tu es où bah
ouais ouais je t'attends 2 minutes je
vais rentrer dis non mais vas-y tu
rentres tout de suite là mais par
exemple si tu rentres pas à 1h45 tu vois
c'est très bien je suis arrivé mamie
[Applaudissements]
mon fils m'a mis dans ta chambre
parce qu'il a fait une bêtise comment
est-ce que vous vous y prenez alors
tu fais quoi sinon quoi c'est sur les
pieds ça veut dire qu'il a tout raté
depuis le début
ant
vous incarnez la paternité moderne vous
n'avez pas du tout à faire office
d'autorité puisque vous incarnez aux
yeux de vos enfants l'autorité naturelle
donc vous n'avez pas besoin d'en
rajouter vous êtes vous êtes dans la
ligne du Conseil de l'Europe et dans la
mienne et je vous félicite pour ça merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est un supportable ces gens et ces
donneurs de leçons c'est je vais vous
dire le plus grand fléau de la terre ce
sont les donneurs de leçons les plus
grands fléaux de la France ce sont les
donneurs de leçons si la France a tous
ces problèmes qu'elle a aujourd'hui
c'est à cause des donneurs de leçons je
le dis et au lit et c'est ça c'est des
donneurs de leçons qui veulent tout vous
dire il faut vous dire ce qu'on doit
regarder il faut vous dire ce qu'on doit
manger ce qu'on veut dire ils vont nous
dire ce qu'on doit ce qu'on a à faire
avec nos enfants et vous nous apprendez
nos enfants ils vont nous apprendre à
conduire ils vont nous apprendre à péter
ils vont nous apprendre à nous casser
les couilles non mais je vous le dis il
commence à me gonfler moi tous les
donneurs de leçons là je ne citerai pas
de nous mais c'est vrai qu'on en peut
plus laissez-nous un peu et je vous lis
à l'époque de nos parents nos
grands-parents il faisait comme ils
sentaient et ça a marché beaucoup mieux
merci donc arrêtez de nous donner des
conseils surtout arrêter de vouloir vous
mêler de tout ça vient maintenant tu
dois te mêler de comment tu dis à ton
oui si tu dois pas ils vont te dire
aussi qu'elle jouait tu vas l'acheter
pour Noël non mais sérieux mais c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable
qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi mamie moi
je suis tellement d'accord avec Mathieu
j'aimerais qu'il m'adopte
pour l'instant il adopte un mec